faer um oops no M so there has been a
change in the schedule I think people
have figured this
house motion thank
you I'm going to start with some some of
a surprising quote from given the source
this is quoting Jason fman who CH of the
Council of economic advisor in the White
House and published in July an article
about the opport unties and challenges
of artificial
intelligence this is interesting
sentence he said even though we have
made as we have not made as much more
recently on other areas of AI such as
logical reasoning the advancement in
deep learning techniques May ultimately
act as at least as a partial substitute
for these other areas so I wish we had
invited him to this
Workshop so a classical problem in
computer science is the bullan
satisfiability problem right this is
kind of the if you want the assembly if
we talk about polic databases as
Assembly Language and these are the the
gates these are the ultimate transistors
of logic and so the modern uh way we
phrase it is we are given a bullan
expression we're going to assume that
it's already in conjunct normal form so
it's a conjunction of the Junctions of
literals and what I do find a satisfying
assignment now have been thinking about
this problems for a long time so we
already find in the in the 19th century
William S Jor William S Jor was a
British Economist and logicians and he
he should get credit for what we call
bullan algebra because bull did not
invent Bull and algebra but jaon bull
use exclusive or rather than inclusive
or and he already writes I've given much
attention to for to lessening was the
manual and the mental labor of the
process and by process he means logical
bull logical reasoning now I shall
describe several devices which may be
adopted for saving trouble and risk of
mistake and he builds the first logic
machine he buil a machine that can do
logical reasoning over four variables if
you're not impressed try to do it with
moving wooden pieces you see it's not so
trivial and then this is an amazing
quote This is er Sher a German
algebraist and he writes getting a
handle on the consequences of any
premises or at least the fced method for
obtaining these consequences seems to me
to be one of the less if not the
ultimate goal of mathematics and logic
nothing short of that and of course we
know that ultimately in the early 70s
cook and LaVine so the bull satisability
is NP complete which kind of explain why
we had over a century before that of
people not finding really any very fast
method for
satisfiability and so but at the same
time as we have the development
complexity Theory people already going
back to the mid starting building
programs for doing essentially bullan
reasoning and the first one is due to
newel show and Simon and they wrote a
program called logic theories and they
were able to prove about 150 theorems
from prip Mathematica about
propositional logic and they wrote to
Russel and Russell was happy and the
next important paper devis and patnam
computational method in calculus it's a
technical report of the National
Security Agency was was not published I
think today it's available but was not
published for many years but I always
made sure I give give them credit
because I know that they are
listening and then two important paper
jcm 1960 and then CM 1962 Davis patnam
and Davis lman in Leland Davis Davis
where is Martin Davis he lives in
Berkeley it's too bad that he's not
here a couple of weeks ago he lives
uphill here okay it's a sh a mile away
from you right now ashamed that he's not
here and and the DPL technique Davis P
Lan became kind of the canonical for
satisfiability and it's a the basic
ideas are rather simple convert it to
CNF use a backtracking search and there
is one euristic that provve to be
effective which is if you have one
Clause remember Clause is a disjunction
so if one Clause is a generate
disjunction then that's the one you're
trying to satisfy first rather than
making a choice of which variable to
satisfy and by
1990 you know we were able to solve
problems with maybe 100 variables and if
you're not impressed with 100 people say
what do you want two to the 100 it's a
large number what do you
expect and then in the mid90s we started
a revolution we still going on and today
we the name has been changed from DPL to
cdcl confli driven Clause learning and
people debate what it is I mean I would
say it's really the the terminology from
Modern sat solver based on on these five
key ideas one is back jumping back
Jumping means when you back track don't
just go one level at a time go as high
as you can you save a lot of time by by
jumping up uh unit close preference unit
close preference preference is as I said
is the key euristic it turns out that
when you do profiling of the code you
spend 80% of the time doing unit
preference and so sudden people realize
this is the thing they need to implement
most efficiently and a naive
implementation people before which was
kind of linear time algorithm for hor
andat essentially was not good enough
and people came up with smarter data
structures and then conflict driven
close learning you backtrack you I mean
you go down you find a conflict you you
you block you don't want to repeat the
same mistake again so you do conflict
analysis you try to identify which part
of the assignments are the bad part and
you want to block that that partial
assignment and you add a new Clause
internal the this new Clause really can
be obtained for by resolution from the
other methods and then H how to choose
variable on which to split people
thought that the goal is to choose the
Val the variable to minimize the size of
the search tree and that means you have
to Choose Wisely but the more wisely you
want to choose the more time it takes to
choose it you know some people you sit
down in a restaurant and they study the
menu and they study the menu and they
study the menu because they want to
Choose Wisely everybody else is done
with dinner they're still choosing and
so idea here is don't spend too much
time choosing chose reasonably well but
don't worry to be the
optimal and that's kind of a dilemma
should you be smart or fast the answer
is some very often smart is better than
fast and then restart which I think B I
think this you guys are the first one to
publish it if I recall which is
sometimes you just say you know you've
you're B down in the search just just
quit it and restart with some new other
random assignments and everything you
have learned so far still relevant so
this key five key sticks and the two
important tool grasp from Michigan in
the mid90s and then sha from Princeton
in around
2000 do any of the her ristics extend to
mod counting uh actually in my opinion
um not all of them but the thing that
I'm amazed that I have not seen in model
counting is is CLA learning because it's
entirely applicable I don't know why
people have not in fact put it in in for
CLA learning you have an explanation
yeah there's a system min2 that uses
Clause learning to compile circuits and
the model counting afterward so there're
cdcl based Doge compilation tools yeah
but I think kind of the main tool for
model counting for some reason I have
not yet caught up there I don't quite
know why and so the amazing thing is
today we can solve problems industrial
problems with millions of
variables and sanjit chesha here from
Berkeley a few years ago run this nice
experiment he took 12 years of s
solvers and run them on a on a 2012
machine on one Benchmark and show us on
this Benchmark Gras p in 800 seconds and
glucose in 2012 took 1 second so we see
three hour of magnitude Improvement
roughly over a decade and it is so
impressive impressive that people talk
about M law for S solvers some social
phenomenon by which we're still
continuing to improve in in such a
dramatic
fashion and in fact amazingly earlier
this year just in the Summer Don kth
received the most preious Award of
Society for industrial and pl
mathematics and he gave the for Norman
lecture and it was about satisfiability
so this is what K is now working is say
about satisfiability in fact he's
working on volume four and by now volume
four has many many sub volume or they're
called fle I learned a new word I guess
I don't know exactly what fasle is
sounds like a face and fle six of volume
four is all about satisfiability which K
called the story of satis ability is the
tale of a Triumph of software
engineering I would have called it
algorithmic engineering rather than
software engineering blended with re do
of beautiful mathematics and some of you
I've heard a few months ago heard in the
news a result in mathematics about
coloring of of Pythagorean triples that
have been proven using such solvers and
the proof is of Si 200 terabyte it's
considered the biggest proof in
mathematics and we have today also
industrial application of such solving
because of this impressive success and
there is a nice CSM paper from four
years ago by lonardo deur and Nicola
bjorner explaining how Z3 an advanced S
solware is being used in Microsoft for
commercial software development so this
is not just an academic Pursuit as we
speak now Microsoft has hundreds of
machine running s solvers for their
software development
practice now what I'd like to do this
was kind of introduction I'd like to
show show you okay now that we have this
what can we do with it and my motivation
original motivation came up from I've
been working for many years in
verification so verification is about
Building Systems and then trying to
ensure whenever you build a system you
have some intention in mind people call
it designer intent how do we know the
system you build actually meet their
designer intent and this is called
functional verification and the estimate
today that that people vary but
somewhere between 70 and 80% of the
design effort is d at not to writing
code but to verifying that the code does
what it's supposed to do now if you live
in Academia you heard a lot of formal
verification and model checking and you
convinced that this is what people do in
practice but um I've done some kind of I
would say this is a bit informal but
I've done some probing and polling okay
asking people okay how many people do
you have doing verification how many of
them do formal how many how many of them
do not do formal and so it turns out
that maybe 10% in some of the advanced
places 10% do formal verification so
what do the rest do they they do what
you do if you write a program you you
put some appropriate test and that's how
you run your program okay I suspect that
very few of you actually very formally
verify the program if you WR program I
don't mean to offend
anybody so this is 90% of the of the of
the verification effort and what you do
essentially and this is I have to say
this is the standard methodology and it
has not changed for the past uh the
basic idea has not CH for the past
probably 60 70 years you run your your
system with different carefully chosen
inputs and for these inputs you you
think you know what the answer should be
and you compare the ideal the reference
answer with the actual answer and of
course the challenge is that if we have
to do it the test space is exceedingly
large in fact take a simple example
imagine that you want to test a floating
point a floating Point divider and this
is example of course he chosen because
about 20 years ago Intel came up with
the the Pentium and the penum couldn't
do proper floating Point Division and so
if you're dealing with 128 bit numbers
then you want to try all combination
there will be two to the 256 and the sun
will go Nova before you're done so we
need a better approach and so the
approach for many years was that you you
hire smart people and are called testers
and what they do they think hard about
the the system you're building and they
think of all kind of corner cases and
they write test to test these particular
cor cases what happen if it's one input
is the two two inputs one is very large
one is very small both are very small
both are very large and things like that
and the conventional wisdom is that
writing a Tesla writing code when you
write code the conventional wisdom is a
programmer writes about two 20 lines per
day whatever is a programming language
that you're doing and the same thing is
roughly true for test in fact about a uh
over 25 years ago I was at IBM and they
built a machine there was called it's an
emulator emulator is a hardware
simulator and it's about 100,000 times
faster than software simulation so they
build this big they bought this big
machine and it cost about $5 million at
a time and for that project which was a
this drive controller they had about 100
test cases so these people would write
you can calculate 100 2,000 test cases
per day and they run them on the
emulator it will be done in about 1
minute and the rest of the day 23 hours
and 15 59 minutes it will sit idle and
somebody was very embarrassed for
investing $5 million in a system it's
being used one minute per day and so
there was a need to increase the
productivity of these people
dramatically and people in IBM hia
research in hia came up with a beautiful
idea don't write test write constraint
that describ scenarios if you want to
say two inputs are very large write
constraints they say these inputs are
both very large and now I use a constant
solver to generate many many solution
and every solution is another test
Vector so to speak okay so this how you
do test generation and this has become
today an iny standard that's how you do
a functional
verification now the question is how do
we get what kind of solution do we want
so of course you have a solver let's
suppose you you you have a solver you
get one of these f m solvers how does it
work you don't know it's a big complex
system and it give you some
solution but you have no idea where the
errors are so you assume that a scenario
a constraint describ a family of test
vectors and what you like to do is to
choose one of them for each test
randomly uniformly because if you if you
have to search somewhere your best
method is to search randomly and
uniformly okay and so otherwise I will
let the internals of the of the solver
influence where I'm looking for the bug
it will be like looking under the under
the under the the light so this gives
right to a following to me very
beautiful mathematical question given a
buan formula generate Solutions
uniformly at random and do it in a
scalable way you want to do it for large
industrial
formulas and interesting in in this is
10 years ago there was a program on on
logic and computational logic comput
logic and algorithm an geni organized
and new Institute and we had a workshop
with an speaker from IBM research
and he described this this was then then
a bit newer than it is today there was
about 10 years old the poach and he
described the this random conent method
and I asked him I said okay how do you
generate Solutions uniformly at random
he said oh we really don't know how to
do it we use all kind of hacks that's
what he told us at the time and so I got
very interested in the problem 10 years
ago it turns out that it has many
applications I talked about concern
random test generation
but if you want just we heard a
beautiful tutorial this morning
about about this rejection sampling for
example so imagine that the guess
program we he this morning just guess
uniformly all bullan assignments and the
Checker checks whether the assignment
satisfy given bullan
formula now the idea is the solution
space is incredibly sparse so if you try
to do naive rejection sampling you will
sample and Sample and Sample forever
before you find a solution so it's not a
good method to do that the question is
how do we actually do it and this is
what I refer to here as Pro problemistic
inference but there's a nice new
application I had recently people who
run Mooks and they have to give
assignment homework and the homework
will be taken by 100,000 students and
there all this discussion forum so if
you give everybody the same problem
somebody will post a solution on the web
and Bang everybody know what the
solution is so you want to generate
100,000 different
problems how do you do that and the
answer is you write constraint to
describe the parameter space and you
generate instances at random and so you
really generate 100,000 different
problems so the theoretician have been
looking at it since the like from about
for the starting about 30 years ago and
um and they solved the problem what does
mean solve the problem two papers first
by J Val and vazirani but then an
improvement by Bel belar G and petan and
they show that you can do you you can do
uniform generation of NP Witnesses in
randomized P time algorithm using an NP
Oracle so problem solved we know how to
do clearly you cannot do better than
using a NP Oracle because you you have
to solve
sat so in 2011 my student School deep
Mill took my logic class and told me
he's interested in research project I
said here is a good one Implement their
algorithm so we implemented what we call
the BJP algorithm and we could get it to
run for 16
variables and then the question was can
we publish it and I said K deep you know
six in variables remember at this point
people all this whole problem with
hundreds of thousands of variables I
said if we send it even to a workshop
people will simply laugh at us this this
will become a joke 16 variables and I
all I could say is well look at Javon he
did four variables we can do 16
variables so we had to go back to the to
the drawing this was really very nice
because we had to go back and redo the
theory so to get algorithm that we can
Implement
efficiently now we also look what people
do in the industry so there are two
really methods to do it one is to use a
binary decision diagram bdds which are
kind of branching programs and if you
have if you are able to build a bdd for
a formula then you do essentially a
random work on the bdd I won't get into
details and you can get a uniform
sampling but we bdds can handle maybe up
to at most about a thousand variables
after that the bdds are just too large
so what do really people do industry
there are two approaches one based on
mcmc and we had again a very nice
theoretical framework for mcmc how you
can do that except that in in general
this mcmc takes you know in this case it
takes exponential time to get to the
stationary distributions so it take way
too long so you stop earlier and then
you really don't know what what's the
quality of what you are getting or what
people do really do in practice they
take solvers in inside the solver they
stick all kind of randomization steps
and they hope that this will some unifor
uniformize the solution space the answer
is it doesn't people run experiment and
you get actually very poor uniformity
you get you get something but you cannot
say anything about
it and so we've been working now for the
past three years on a new framework
called unen by now we have several
versions of it and it is similar to bgp
in the sense it's a randomized poam
algorithm calling a SAT or NP Oracle
what is NP Oracle it's a SAT Oracle so
we have program calling sat as a black
box not quite I'll explain how it's
different than pure sat solver and what
we get is almost uniform generation
which I explain and the idea where we
using ideas that some are very old
Universal hashing again it's a 30y old
idea beautiful idea from theoretical
computer science and we're using very
Cutting Edge St technology it's called
SMD solver I'll mention explain it in a
minute and today we can handle millions
of variables so we are able to handle
industrial size
problems so first of all where do you
compromise you compromise on on a
uniformity so if you have a solution
space with copper solution then a
uniform probability would be that every
solution is chosen with probability one
over Capa and we have this is a slightly
different formulation which is explained
my questions earlier about differential
privacy uh this is essentially you be
you have a a tolerance of 1 plus Epsilon
and you multiply the probability from
above and below or divide by 1 plus
Epsilon so if you take Epsilon to be
let's say 0.1 it means that you are
within 10% of your uniform probability
and Epsilon is a parameter here you'll
see of course as the smaller Epsilon
you'll pay the price for it so this is
almost
uniform now what is the basic idea so
the basic idea goes back to again to
work by C and vman and then and then
sipel and then be had be used by by for
example the reduction from NP to up use
similar ideas so these are not new ideas
you take the solution space and you
divide it into roughly equal small
cells and then you choose a cell at
random and the cells are small in a cell
has a small number of solution so you
can enumerate precisely the number of
solutions in the cell and then you
choose randomly one among them if the
cell are roughly equal then this would
give you an almost uniform
distribution now the difficult part is
how do I take a set of solution which I
know nothing about it's a mysterious set
all I can do is a s solver can tell me
can say it's empty or not empty and how
do I divide it into uniform cells and
here come the magic of universal hashing
so hashing of course is one of the most
fundamental ideas in computer science in
many many application we need to to map
a very large set to a much much smaller
set okay you have a on your computer
think of it you have all the maybe every
password is I don't know there must be
some limit let's say 50 characters long
and you have to take the huge space and
you have to store it and the only way to
store it is to map it to much smaller
space so generally we map 01 to the N
for large n to 01 to the N for a much
much smaller M so m is much smaller than
n now if you go back to early papers on
hushing the discussion what is a good
hush function a good hush function takes
a roughly random set of inputs and
preserve the randomness so if you start
with a roughly roughly random input
space you'll get a roughly random output
space but if you have a very bad initial
distribution there's no guarantee what
will happen to the output space and then
came the idea of universal has function
the idea is that because you don't know
anything about the input distribution
you randomize over it right this is a
really a fundamental idea that probably
comes from game theory that if you know
nothing randomize so you have a family
of has function you choose one hash
function
randomly and that will guarantee that
whatever was the initial distribution
the output distribution will be roughly
uniform turns out that you need more
than that because one thing you could do
you choose a random output and then you
take all the inputs and and map it map
all of them to this one random output
which you chose incredibly well of
course this will be very bad because all
these different inputs will not be met
independently and so you want some
notion of Independence and how much
independent depends on the application
and generally people talk about R
Universal hash function and R universal
mean that every R input values are up
independently and the higher they are
the more the nicer thing you can say
about the range for example the variance
of the of the distribution not just the
the expectation but also in higher
moments and the way to get R
universality is to use polinomial of
degree R minus one so there is you can
do it but in some you have to use more
and more expensive tools to get higher
in
dependence and this is a very critical
issue because higher universality means
higher complexity so bgp wrote a
theoretical paper so they went one why
don't we do n universality where N is a
number of variables so they had to use
polinomial of of of high degree
polinomial but they got nice result all
the cells were small and they got
uniform
distribution but this High degree
polinomial when you try to reduce them
to sat give us very very complex
formulas and therefore we could not they
remember that's why we couldn't scale
more than 16 variables so what we had to
go back is to show that you can actually
work with three
universality uh I believe that this
should be done with two universality
just per wise independent should be
enough but we've not been able to prove
it yet but with three universality we
can show that every a random cell is
small with high probability that gives
us almost uniform generation and that
that by that is the key idea that enable
us to go one key idea enable us to go
from tens of variables to by now
millions of variables and we get the
statement we get a running time we can
say similar to what bgp had which is
polinomial in the side of the formula in
one / Epsilon of course relative to a
SAT
Oracle now the SEC how do we actually
build a hash function so again we're
using ideas that have been have been
discussed before and this is using
random exr constraints so normally we
think that a a clause is is a in
disjunction of variable this case we
take a a in exclusive disjunction of
variables so we choose the variables
with probability half so every variable
either get in or not with probability
half and then the sum is chosen again to
be zero or one with probability half so
you can think of it it's a linear
equation modulo two where the a variable
gets in with probability half and every
every Clause has roughly n/ two
variables and I'll come back to this
point so the idea is we're taking the
solution space we're taking think of it
as a random hyper plane and we split it
essentially in two and then we do it
again and again and again and again if
we do it m times we get two to the m
cells and the cells are going to be
fairly large fairly small and of course
M has to be chosen very carefully in
fact we don't know initially what is M
and part of the algorithm is to find out
the right
M but as a result what we get that every
cell is now described by initial CNF CL
set of clauses plus exor
Clauses so we thought okay very easy to
convert exor Clauses to standard closet
just use the tightening and coding it's
very easy to do this turns out to be a
terrible idea in fact even you take just
take X or constraint by themselves
they're just linear equations modul of
two so you can solve them in polinomial
time using gaus and elimination in fact
there are solver that will do just that
for you but if you reduce them to CNF
and you give to S solver it will per
terribly it doesn't know that these are
exra constraints it will run the
backtracking search and it will run
forever and in particular the
combination of CNF andx or is a nastic
combination if you try to just use a
standard s
solver now here comes the other idea
which is the smt solving and so roughly
starting around 2,000 after after people
realize that s solvers are taking off
and people say can we do more expressive
constraints can we build on this success
to handle Boolean plus other type of
constraints such as linear arithmetics
and and um and others and have been
tremendous progress since 2000 and these
are heavily used today and we happen to
stumble really stumble just pure luck
which stumbl upon an smt solware called
Crypt minad Dev developed by matus and
his colleagues and they really were
looking at combination of CNF and EXO
constraints and they wanted to use it to
break cryptographic keys because
cryptographic keys are bit Vector so
they thought if they can they can
somehow use Sat by itself does not work
you cannot break you cannot do uh for
example you cannot do primality testing
or or factor numbers using sat they
thought maybe if we add X or we can do
it was the total failure they put it
away the guy left Academia went to
industry but the solver was still there
and the solver is actually very
effective on this combination because it
combine sving with gaus and elimination
in a in a clever
way so we have a tool down now and so
one of the thing remember it does almost
uniform so would interesting to say how
what is almost uniform how uniform is
almost uniform so here is a what an
experiment we run on a problem with
16,000 Solutions we did about 4 million
samples and for each for each solution
we counted how many times it been
selected can you Briefly summarize how
how the sampler actually works so you
you run you you comput the cells and
then you you it has two it has two
phases one there is a search of this
magic parameter M and M has to find
roughly how many extra concerns do we
need so we get small cells okay and then
we create this random this random EXO
constraints we put it with a formula we
give it to Crypt minisat Krypt minisat
uh enumerate the Solutions in a Cell
It's a random cell we count the solution
this is has to be usually a few dozens
of solution we choose one of them at
random okay but there is a part actually
the more there is a part that one has to
implement very carefully which is how to
find as efficiently as you can it's a
search algorithm how to find the right
number the right number of Exel
constraints because if you put too many
the problems become too heavy you cannot
solve it if you put too few then you get
cell that are too loud you have to find
just the the goldilock number of XR
constraints so in this case we counted
how many times every solution is
obtained and this have to in the limit
to give you a poron distribution
but instead of comparing to Pon we
actually implemented a real uniform
sampler specifically for this problem
since there are 16,000 Solutions and we
know we know them all and uh these are
the two plots of the counts of each
Solutions and these are stat
statistically
indistinguishable so what's interesting
this is done if we can if we make
Epsilon too small we pay the price so we
took your Epsilon to be about 75 and
still we get something that looks very
uniform to
us in terms of performance We compare
comp to EXO sample Prime that came from
Cornell which was a urtic some very
important ideas but it was still a urtic
sampler which mean it gave in particular
it gave no guarantee on uniformity and
now we we and we are able then to
outperform it by two to three orders of
magnitude so we have a method now that
that does it does this kind of almost
uniform sampling which give you a
guaranteed almost uniformity and
performs um almost ready to Industrial
appli ations if you ask me at the break
I'll tell you what almost ready
means and this give us the ambition to
go back to Counting we've heard about
counting before and so as again if Dan
said that polic databases are the
Assembly Language of counting then
propositional model counting is the
transistors of of logical counting and
except that it's actually a hard problem
so sat is still a hard problem I'll talk
more about what is SAT but we know that
in practice we can solve today sat for
problem with millions of variables
but sharpa to count variables to count
Solutions we can scale up to maybe
50,000 variables but not for bigger
formulas so so whatever the the
theoretical difference it's a much
harder problem in practice and again it
has many many applications we had enough
about it so I will not talk about about
the applications of model counting
here now again this problem have been
studied by by theoreticians again this
the idea is actually to do what's called
pack Counting so many people heard of
pack learning but pack came first in the
context of counting of approximate
counting you w probably approximately
correct they probably refer again to
some tolerance one plus Epsilon that you
want to have and in addition it's a
randomized algorithm and you want a
success probability to be at least
Delta and again jum Val and Sinclair
show this is in B BPP to the NP and
there has been no implementation of
these ideas until uh until we approached
it and actually if the initial ideas
were implemented they would not work for
the same reason that the bgp algorithm
did not work I mean they were not ready
for actual
implementation but it turns out that the
idea of universal hashing Works
effectively here because once we have a
small cell we can count the precisely
the Solutions in a Cell multiply by 2 to
the m and we get an estimate now it's
just an estimate if you run it if you
sample enough time you can and take the
median or the average doesn't matter you
can get an estimate to desired level of
confidence okay so the question is how
many time you need to sample and the
answer is it's it's polinomial in in log
of 1 minus Delta in this
case so we were able to compare it on
places where with the ground truth so to
speak so this our problem with at most
50,000 variables and we compare it to
what was at the time the set of the art
counter C and what was interesting is
that even though we use Epsilon 75 on
all the problem up to that the ker was
able to solve our accuracy was always
within
4% so so the method actually is much
more effective even than we can prove
analytically and again it
outperforms Cas dramatically C usually
can handle as as I say if C does not
normally stop in five minutes you might
as well give up it will never stop but
we can have a problem with hundreds of
thousands of
variables so one issue that comes up we
have long extra closes on the average
they have n/ two and this has been the
people have tried now very hard for the
last few years to see can we use much
shorter exor closes because they will
give you Improvement in performance and
there are various combinator lemas that
argue why short extra closer should be
good enough but it turns out to connect
to to tie all the threats together which
is to prove comor LMA to have an
algorithm with provable properties in
implement this algorithm with no magical
number so to speak so honest
implementation experiments does not
require extra judicial uh uh involvement
from the experimenter it's actually
quite hard to do and I think the the
jury is out whether we can use short
extra clauses I have seen nothing yet
that says that it's actually provably
works I want to finish with some kind of
a bit of a
philosophical thinking about this so I
think one thing I'm trying to
communicate is that something amazing
happened I said I really don't deser any
credit for it this is all the work on
Sat is the work of other people I was
deeply skeptical when I heard the
initial papers but today I think we have
such amazing progress this deserve
better publicity and partly I think is
better terminology I think s solving is
for for us for the for the general
public deep
solving and the other thing I show you
that once you have something like that
you have a big Hummer if you have a big
Hummer look for else what else can we do
with it I give you one example here
which is sampling and counting but what
else can we do and I have to say we
should not assume that scalability is
not a challenge anymore people continue
to work on S solver to make them more
scalable and we are continuing to work
on approximate sampling and counting to
make them more scalable there are still
challenges but I think this result
really should force us to go and uh
rethink some of our very basic
assumption about theory and practice in
computer science so when I was a
freshman student one of the of the
gradas asked us what is the difference
between theory and practice and none of
us had a good answer and he says well in
theory they're very they're very similar
but in practice they're very different
and so I think this was very s advice so
P versus NP is of course a beautiful
mathematical question we can talk a lot
about it but if we solve it either way
it's not clear that it will really have
any practical impact because you could
prove that P equal n p but the the
polinomial will be n to the th000 in
fact it doesn't even have to be n to the
th000 even the polinomial of degree n to
the 10 make the algorithm really
impractical think about it take n to the
10 Take N equal 100 and that's it you're
done or we could prove that P is
different than NP but all of NP may be
included in N to the log log log n and
this is this is maybe even as good as
any polinomial and so there's no
guarantee that solving P ver P will need
any practical benefits
now when I was a graduate student that
was considered a scary problem you know
you you look at it like this you
approach it like a like a bomb right you
look at it very carefully you approach
it with a after you wore in a vest and S
you know I'm not trying to say that sat
is an easy problem because we know how
to generate very difficult sat instances
okay we can generate s instances with a
few hundred variables that no solver can
solve but nevertheless there's something
iCal about the problem that come up in
real life nobody understand why but we
able to solve huge problems and just
explaining it I think is is a wonderful
challenge okay how can we explain why
some problems inside are so easy and why
and some are so are so
hard and but on the other side is this
is for the theory how can we leverage
the fact that in real life many s
instances seem to be very easy what else
can we do with it okay should we think
of BPP to NP as the up time thank you
very
much okay
questions so it's a comment more than a
question the comment is that I don't
really know why you say that these are
evolutions of the theoretical algorithms
because they really look the same to me
say again they really look the same to
me what looks the same to you your
algorithm as the theoretical one they
use parse Independence the theoretical
ones as well
and I have to say if you look at aora
Barak for example the book The Textbook
on complexity Theory aora and Barak they
have exactly this same schema for
approximate counting so no no I I
actually I said that these are these are
all these are not new algorithm these
are just in some sense refinement of all
algorithms but partly you had to do in
refin analysis to show you have to use a
particular hash functions and you have
to prove that this hash function have
this is probability properties that you
need and then part of the thing is that
don't assume just because you have an
algorithm the imple implementation does
not matter implementation matters a lot
so so this was to me an idea of taking
the old Theory and implementing it see
it doesn't work and then kind of redoing
it in a way to get it something that
does work so it is clearly I'm not
trying to say these are all all set of
old ideas yeah to to answer your
question to some extent using crypto
minisat is actually the really important
part that you don't take the exce and
try to convert convert them to closes
and solve them closly that actually buys
you a
lot I would say is you know the there is
if you look at the paper you will see
there is I mean mostly is
a kind of closing all the threads
proving that the has function have the
desired universality properties proving
prop of the algorithm because we want to
have an algorithm which we can say it
converges in certain amount of time you
have to you have to search for the right
number of EX or concerns it's actually
nonrival part of the algorithm so there
a theory there that I would say I would
not call it a it's not completely new
it's really taking a whole bunch of
ideas and re walk them to do it and then
there is algorithmic engineering part to
make everything
work your conclusion that we need a rich
and broader complexity Theory explaining
us what is really difficult what is
really hard I mean I've heard that one
also a very long time ago already and
not in fact not just uh apply to S but
apply to undecidable problems in fact
that we also routinely solve in practice
so why is this problem so hard that you
posted 20 years ago also in in some of
your talks but there I don't think I we
can go back to my talk from 20 years ago
I would say is we can I've been talking
about it now because they've been the
same you we can look at the last 10
years we see progress for example in in
program termination so it's even worse
right this undecidable problem and that
they don't be so much difficult in
practice and in each case there seem to
be something in this problem that arise
in real life that makes them easier I
actually understand it better for
program termination than I understand it
here because program termination when I
write a program and it terminates or
does not terminate it is not due to some
deep mathematical reason if it
terminates it's because usually fairly
simple reasoning and if it does not
terminate it's usually due to some
stupid reason so it's not as if my
deration of my program depends on exter
and hypothesis okay okay it is a there
is very simple reason for either
termination or non-termination because
none of us thinks when you write a
program on incredibly incredibly
complicated termination argument and so
there psychological reason as to why
this termination problem in real life
are actually fairly easy I do not quite
understand why these complex circuits
that come from Intel are easy that I do
not understand okay yeah insulting
instances as you say with hundreds of
thousands of of of variables how
important is the role of backbones and
uh back door sets so um I would say it
depends it depends on the CD cell
solvers so so one of the thing there's a
lot of work now people trying to explain
find explanation find structure in this
formula will explain why they're so easy
people have looked at backbones does not
seem to be a good explanation fails on
formulas with 300 variables I've used it
it fails at 300 variables say it again I
have used MC and it often times fails on
VAR formulas with 300 variables right
but you say it works for tens or
hundreds of thousands of variables so
there's some discrepancy there and I'm
trying to understand what feature of
those formulas is it that enables the
algorithm so I mean one thing about your
formula I would say is if you have such
formulas first of all let's try it will
be actually interesting I know but there
are there are some formulas s fail on
them okay s work on them yeah so I mean
look part of the issue is that we really
you know we are star to investigate
you've seen some of our war we to
understand what happen when you take
problems and you in random EXO
constraints so the initial argument was
s solver Works nicely on formula the the
formula we you we are generating here
are not purely industrial formulas
because the industrial formulas plus
random EXO constraints what does it do
so we're only now starting to
investigate what happened when you take
such formula and you combine CNF and XR
we're only the beginning of this in this
in this investigation and so I said
answering most questions you're going to
ask I said beats me all right we'll have
one more question so the so uh this is
maybe quite naive but I'm
wondering have you seen any fruitful
smooth
analysis of this type of problem as a
step towards getting a the gap between
the formal settings which give us this
Grim picture and this mysterious real
world problem generators so people
always ask me these questions and it
implied the smooth analysis explain for
example why linear programming problems
why Simplex not just linear why Simplex
seem to work so well on linear problem
linear programming problems Min
understand of smooth of smooth analysis
it talks about robustness of solving it
does not explain why if you just take a
problem then over you put it you run it
you run Simplex on it it's a huge
problem has million many millions of
variable The Matrix it can be S A
Million by million it's sparse and
Simplex finishes in reasonable amount of
time I don't see how smooth anal analy
explained that so I don't quite know you
know if the goal is to explain why we're
solving problems the idea if I measure
the coefficients from The Real World
yeah for example there's measurement
noise so so that smooth analysis
explains well that this measur noise is
not so important okay the problem here
this is a very discret problem I've
tried very hard to find some analog and
I if you have great ideas I would it
would be wonderful I couldn't find what
is the the the analogous idea because
these are very discret issue discret
problem and we know that you take this
formula you change you flip one variable
that's it it will go from sat to unset
okay they they're they're not robust
they don't have the robustness that you
have in linear programming so it will be
I think it's a it's a I have I thought
myself about this question many people
ask me and I my answer is I have no idea
how to even apply this
approach okay thank you
all right so now we have a coffee break
and we return at
[Applause]